combat medic Danish midov shows us a
Macabre collection he calls the Museum
of tourniquets that kill tourniquets
donated to Frontline Maddox in Ukraine
to make a difference between life and
death unfortunately these tourniquets
are useless they cannot stop the
critical bleeding they will not work
they will not save their life some of
them are married in USA some of them
this one was made in Israel
like I've taken it on on the front line
from the Israeli volunteer I've taken it
say like I said give this one to me and
I will give you normal one young just
returned from the front line where he
says soldiers urgently need equipment to
operate blood and evacuation vehicles
is very necessary because there are a
lot of soldiers coming to our
stabilization point the Russians are
storming our position and they are very
good at using drones
for a group called Ukrainian Fighters is
suing first aid kits sent from Poland
before soldiers can use them not all
medical donations are reaching the front
lines the authorities are currently
investigating The Disappearance of first
aid kits worth one million dollars sent
by the us since the start of the war
several officials including the deputy
defense minister have lost their jobs
after corruption involving support for
the military was uncovered
president zelenski recently said he had
no more tolerance for officials who
would jeopardize Ukraine's
anti-corruption Drive needed for EU
admission aware of the risks relief
centers like this one register all
donations
I think that corruption is very bad and
corruption with medical supplies is the
worst thing that can happen moreover
this is the moment when human life is
very very valuable
with fighting intensifying human lives
are increasingly at stake combat Medics
urged the government not only demand
more weapons but focus on medical
supplies too if we will not provide the
best medical help to our Warriors we
will lose this war because uh if all our
wounded soldiers will die who will be
who will be fighting to save lives
well-functioning tourniquets are badly
needed like the ones Danish midov shows
us step fashion Al Jazeera khakif
Ukraine
workers unions are rallying across
Nigeria
foreign